what's going on guys in this video i'm going
to explain every warmer titan in the history of
attack on titan ranging from nearly 2 000 years
ago all the way up to the present day of the
series as we found out in season 4 the warhammer
has a unique ability to create basically anything
it wants out of titan hardening as well as being
able to remotely control the titan from inside a
crystal for the warhammer titans that we probably
know i'll be explaining the backstory of that user
in addition to what makes their titan unique
and for the other warhammers throughout history
i'll be commenting on their designs plus
giving a few theories about a couple of them
be sure to like subscribe if you want to see more
videos like this and let me know in the comments
which titan you think i should cover next okay so
the first warmer titan on this list is lara tiber
who was a member of the prestigious tiber
family for at least a few hundred years
the tiber family had exclusive possession of the
warhammer titan with lara being the final one of
them to have it since the events of the great
titan war their family secretly ruled mali from
the shadows with her older brother willie being
the leader of their clan on her first appearance
in the series she stood quietly in the background
before dishing out a plate for her nephew
and at the time many viewers either didn't
notice her or just assumed she was the maid
as time progressed we got a small hint that she
might be important as she was the only family
member that willie brought to the declaration
of war yeah in hindsight i think she should
have stayed home lara's warhammer titan had
a thin shell of hardening covering his body
but his eyes and mouth was still partly visible
thanks to the stripy design that it had in those
areas it had an interesting semi-circle pattern
on both sides of its neck and its physicality was
like a skinnier version of the attack titan pique
stated that the tibers never used their titan
against an enemy nation meaning that lara's battle
with erin was the first ever real fight she had
that makes it even more impressive that she was
able to create at least seven different weapons
or structures during their battle with the best
for me being the crossbow or the giant pillar
in a kind of ironic twist lara's final words
were her asking aaron if he had any final words
and yeah she was eaten about 10 minutes after
that the next warhammer titan is none other than
eren yeager who mercilessly stole the power after
using porco as a nutcracker unlike his predecessor
aaron does not come from a noble bloodline and
was just a regular kid born within the walls of
parodies island who had a burning desire to see
the outside world when he was 10 years old the
warriors of mali launched their attack on paradise
with aaron's mother being eaten by a titan in the
process on that same day aaron's father grisha
used the power of his attack titan to steal the
founding titan from the royal family grisha would
then forcibly give these abilities to his son with
aaron not realizing that he had titan powers until
years later at 19 years old aaron infiltrated mali
by himself going undercover as a wounded aldean
soldier his primary goal was to collect his
half-brother zeke and bring him back to paris
island but along the way he would do to marley
what was done to him as a child using the power
of his attack titan aaron would kill willie tiber
malian military generals innocent citizens of
liberio and politicians from around the world
his final victim was lara tiber as he would
use the biting strength of poco's jaw titan to
forcibly destroy the crystal that lara was in by
drinking the contents of her spine aaron inherited
the warhammer titan and is the first character
we know to have three titan shifters in one body
aaron's warhammer titan has not yet appeared in
the anime so pause the video now if you're an
anime only as from this point on i will be talking
about spoilers as usual i would encourage you to
come back to this video once the final season
is over but until then you probably don't want
to continue with that said eren's warmer titan
looks exactly the same as his regular titan form
as he seemingly chose not to use his new power to
create a white shell around his skin he definitely
could have done this if he had the desire to do
so but i guess you shouldn't fix what's not broken
even without the typical warhammer titan look
aaron was very proficient with this power as he
created massive spikes out of the ground that even
pierced through the armored titan this however was
not the first time he had used this power as his
previous achievements include busting himself
out of his underground cell and then sealing off
his escape route so that no one could follow him
moving on we're going to talk about the designs
of the other warhammer titans throughout history
including a theory i have that i think makes
perfect sense these titans all made appearances
in the final arc of attack on titan so without
further ado let's start with the robocop warhammer
titan this one has the sturdiest looking helmet of
all the warhammer titans out there but the mouth
is completely uncovered which is a feature that
you don't normally see with this specific titan
it has three horizontal slits around the eye
area but beyond that the rest of his body is
pretty standard as far as warmer titans go like i
said the design is possibly inspired by robocop i
mean that's the thing that came to my mind but
whether it is or isn't it still looks awesome
we first saw this titan when it manifested a
bow and arrow and during that same bone arrow
scene there were a bunch of other warhammer titans
with unique designs this one here had flowing hair
coming out the back which is not something you
typically see from a warhammer titan and these
two here had headgear that sort of reminded me
of chainmail armor or executioner style headgear
like i don't know it has a medieval feel to it
for most of the titans in that particular scene
we don't know which era they came from but i can
tell you a theory that i have about this warmer
titan right here with the circular markings on his
face remember the anime already confirmed that the
white shell that covers most warhammer titans is
made from the same hardening that they use for
their weapons that means they must have control
over how their shell looks in the same way they
have control over their other creations you're
probably wondering why i'm bringing this up and
to get straight to it my theory is that this draw
titan right here was potentially a close friend of
this warhammer titan their designs are so similar
that what i'm thinking is the draw titan inherited
this strange design and then when the warhammer
titan got their titan they decided to mould their
armor so it matched their friend i would say
though that these two cannot be related by blood
because all of the nine titans were held by
different families so the type of family had the
warhammer and a separate unknown family had the
draw so i'm thinking that the draw just happened
to get this design and then the warhammer kind of
emulated it to match their their body essentially
anyway up next we have this panel here and there
are two specific warhammers that i want to point
out i suspect that this warhammer in the back
is the first weimar titan to ever exist as in
chapter 122 we saw pretty much the first iteration
of every titan starting with the first founding
titan and then later in the chapter we see the
remaining eight in a brief panel its notable
features include his hair the lines around his
eyes and mouth and the lines around his stomach
area which is not something that we've seen like
this before this is reminiscent of lara typer's
design as she did have lines around her eyes and
mouth as well but i mean the first warhammer did
take it a step further by having it around this
area the other one i wanted to point out was
this warhammer standing on top of rhino primarily
because it created a scythe out of titan hardening
that is not a weapon i've seen any other wilma
titan make so maybe just a quick theory on that is
that during the great titan war maybe this guy was
like an executioner where he would go around like
decapitating other uh titan shifters during battle
who know that he's just a guest but uh this was a
very specific weapon choice in chapter 135 we
saw a few more interesting warmer titans with
this one here being especially freaky its mouth
has a partition where there is just bare flesh
and the shell in the center of its forehead forms
this weird triangle over here when we look in the
background we can see the cloaked warhammer titan
which seemingly has a flexible cloak draped over
its body thanks to lara tiber's whips we already
knew that the warhammer could make bendable titan
hardening and this one here used that ability
to full effect by giving themselves a nice
titan dressing gown the final warhammers that i
thought were worth mentioning include this one
that attacked reiner as it had an interesting
pattern on the front and back of his head
over here we have a unique titan whose entire
face was partially covered in hardening this
one was funny because the design is pretty
cool on the surface but at the same time it
just looks so uncomfortable like many of the
other warhammer titans i would imagine that
his vision is at least partially blocked but
for some reason the warmer titans don't seem
to mind having designs that block large portions
of their eyes in the comments below let me know
which was your favorite warhammer titan design
and also tell me which titan shifter you want
to see next be sure to drop a like as it does up
out the video and until the next one peace out